Did you know Thanksgiving and many of its modern traditions can be traced back almost 400 years?
In search of religious freedom from the Church of England,...
...a group of English settlers known as the Pilgrims washed up on the shore of Plymouth, Massachusetts in 1620.
Unprepared for the harsh New England winter,...
...tragedy struck as crops died and many of the settlers did not survive.
What saved the Pilgrims was a Native American man from the Wampanoag tribe by the name of Squanto.
Squanto befriended the settlers and taught them how to grow corn, squash and beans:...
...crops that could survive in the climate.
By the fall of 1621, the crops were thriving.
It was truly a miracle and one worth celebrating.
So the settlers asked the local Native Americans to join them in a harvest home celebration,...
...a custom they brought from Europe.
The two cultures joined in a new world harvest home that lasted for three days...
...and included games, songs, and of course, a memorable feast.
We commonly refer to this feast as the first Thanksgiving.
But many things, including the food, were quite different from our celebrations today.
While the settlers may have feasted on wild turkey,...
...it's likely they also dined on goose, rabbit, codfish, and lobster.